these racks and shelves contain a lot of
books for thousands of years we humans
have been pretty good at the whole
reading thing and in most places we do
it the same way we start with our eyes
on one side of the page and we move them
across to the other a new company called
spritz kind of looking to change all of
that instead of presenting words and
sentences that our eyes scan over it
presents words sequentially one after
another why would you want to read this
way well there may be two benefits for
starters if you're presenting things
word by word you don't actually need a
very large display to read longer text
and in fact Samsung has hooked up with
spritz to include that technology on its
latest line of smartwatches but there
may be a second benefit eighty percent
of our time reading is actually spent
moving our eyes from word to word and
refocusing on each one if we don't have
to do that anymore in this case the
words come to us we can read sprit says
aster according to the company's
research people using spritz often
settle in at around 350 to 400 words per
minute that's about twice as fast as
normal and there are some outliers
reading it a thousand words per minute
research has shown that after about 650
words per minute comprehension starts to
fall off a cliff but in some cases it
might actually not be so bad spritz says
they want to account for 15% of all
reading within two years that's a pretty
lofty goal but the company thinks it can
make some inroads into the shorter form
reading that we all are doing no you're
probably not going to read war and peace
while using spritz but checking a
crowded inbox while you're waiting for a
train standing a quick text message on
your wrist increasingly there's a whole
body of reading that has less to do with
comprehending and digesting and more to
do with just kind of glancing at and
burning through
you